I don't think I've ever had Israeli food
but I also don't know what food I have
had
[Music]
so you pronounce it Peters guitar Peters
guitar I love beautiful time okay how
good these words love the sesame seeds
sounds like a Kiki pizza yeah that was a
workout it's really good except they
forgot the sauce the cheese and the
pepperoni drive does it come with any
dipping sauces
it tastes like dust Israeli cheeto dust
yeah it should be more like pizza whoa
cool it is ha ha
they over-investing in sesame seeds one
year and they're like we're just gonna
use it on everything this is our main
export sesame seed
what's sesame see how well they stay on
I'm gonna leave whoo it's flaky I
appreciate that you like flaky things
rule number one - making Israeli food it
just it has to crumble everywhere is
there something in it I'm a big block
and cheese in the middle that's where
the magic is oh my god breakfast lunch
and dinner please I would love to dip it
into marinara sauce what food all over
my face
no oh so beak oh wow okay so Bernie it's
got a lot of things going on now this
looks scary it's not like the nicest
looking thing it's like a sandwich that
you left in your lunch bag and then sat
on it or something do we use our hands
whole medley of stuff in here yeah it is
just bursting at the seams with the
gooey stuff this is basically like a
five course meal with in a PITA that's a
lot of like meals one culinary journey I
do not want to go on it's like it's like
a hot pocket but but good for me this is
a winner go Israel Joshua the famous
Marvel hero this looks Italian that's
just because it's red I can't say I'm a
fan of the presentation Oh No the
textures weird this looks like an
eyeball as the eggs
booooo-whoo I see you know what tastes
exactly what it looks like and you wash
your hands before this Oh Israeli good
more food more food more Israeli Israeli
food
food more food Israeli food booze more
food I want more Israeli food give me
some more yeah